hi everyone it's jerry i'm on chess.com
tactics trainer
i'm going to try three puzzles and go
ahead and share my thoughts along the
way
so
well
uh this first puzzle
if you are connected
with me on facebook you'll know that
i've posted this one
on my uh
on my
page
i'm not sure what game this was from but
this is a very popular puzzle the answer
is g3
this is an interference move
we have this idea of getting to c8
for mate
g3 attacks the queen and threatens me
and you really can't
hope for a better first move
you're leaving the queen
you know a couple different ways should
be she could be captured but g4 is a
really cool interference move for this
one
well
that one was really quick let's try
another one let's try puzzle two
uh
probably a very cool puzzle if you have
not seen that one before g4
okay
um
team white
and what do we do
okay
if we promote right away
then we're just going to get hit with
the fork
we could still do that though
this is a cool puzzle
nice um
we could promote still allow the fork
and my initial reaction was to move the
king towards the center but
we promote to a queen knight here
check king h6 and after knight takes
queen we give mate
with g7
that's cool
we allow the four king h6
that's a cool finish okay this might be
the quickest
uh
group of three puzzles
let's see last one here puzzle three
team black
okay
we have this check
we have a couple different checks
queen f2 queen g1
on queen
f2 if king h1 queen g1 is made queen f2
king h3
queen f2 if the bishop blocks we win the
queen she's unprotected so queen giving
check out one of these two squares
well if the bishop moves
then we pick up the queen
queen check
king h3
queen f1
on queen f1 king h2 there's bishop check
king h1
bishop f2 check king
h2
queen g1 check king h3 queen g3 mate
there's one other variation to consider
queen f2 king h3 queen f1 check
king
g4 now what
nothing is coming to mind
with that one
queen f2 king h3
queen f1 check
king g4
now what
where's the next check
this square is covered
my queen has it
and if we don't come up with something
fast we're going to be getting hit with
checks ourselves
hmm
is this not the first move here
this is tricky
let's see
how to control these light squares
this square is covered
like if this bishop wasn't here queen
here maybe in some variations could be
made the queen's there to block but
um
we don't have any fear of like losing
this position is what i'm getting at
um
queen check king here
i'm not seeing a difference be between
queen g1 and queen f2 maybe that would
help me to solve this puzzle if i could
find a difference between these two
because they seem
i just i don't i don't see a difference
between the two and sometimes finding
the difference between these two squares
could be
helpful to
solving this puzzle
don't really see it though i don't see
much difference
it's weird
um
we have this past pawn there is like a
queen trade gonna be helpful probably
not
opposite color bishops
um
not having the correct pawn here
to promote with this dark square bishop
hmm
what am i missing queen f2
oh there must be one quiet move here
is that what it is
ah there's a quiet move
sneaky quiet moves yeah that's what it
is queen f2 king h3 bishop here
there's no way to stop queen takes pawn
here successfully on the next turn
there is a difference between these two
squares
queen g1 king here
bishop d6 would now allow bishop to g2
interfering with the coordination on
this square
okay
queen f2 it is and one quiet move to
finish this
right here
notice this stops both checks by the
white queen
queen f4 and queen to f8
very interesting i like the first two
uh the best but this one was quite
interesting as well this
silent move to finish off
the puzzle not a good way to now defend
against g3
okay well that's all for right now these
are the only three that i'm gonna do
feel free to share how you did with them
and i'll catch you in the next video
take care bye
you